entre les deux il y a un air de famille
mais seulement nerfs dans le paysage
lyonnais le crayon de la part-dieu signe
les contrats du nouveau quartier des
affaires de lyon à vaulx en velin la
tour sert vraiment à grimper demain soir
isabelle pâtissier troisième de la coupe
du monde hépatite b road le grimpeur de
l'impossible dans tron la face sud du
mas-du-taureau une première mondiale
patrick béraud est le dernier de la
charte des 19 plus grands alpinistes le
monde a refusé toujours la notion de
compétition rendue possible grâce aux
surfaces artificielles sa présence ici
est un symbole non l'acteur d' escalade
n'est pas réservée au sport de haut
niveau avant tout elle est la composante
d'un immeuble d'habitation à loyer
modéré dans une ville autrefois de
mauvaise réputation une convention entre
l'état la communauté urbaine de lyon et
membre à réhabiliter le quartier entre
eux dans l' escalade tout court contre
celle de la violence et ça marche la
petite délinquance est en chute libre à
vaulx en velin les enfants des écoles
apprennent à grimper comme à nager dans
le cadre du tiers-temps pédagogique à
l'origine il y à alain monde et y
travaillent à redescendre dans la
planète rapporté la montagne aux enfants
de la ville puisque la recherche la
verticale est la première activité du
petit dock
c'est lui l'inventeur du mur arc en ciel
qui a fait des petites partout en france
comme outil pédagogique
mais le mur c'est dépassé voici la tour
deux ans de travaux souffrent avec son
sommet à géométrie variable
c'est la seule structure artificielle au
monde capable de reproduire toutes les
situations des milieux naturels la
montagne de l'oci sans aucun danger et
regarder les gens ici dire la couverture
mais attention le but n'est pas
d'enfermer la montagne dans un bocal et
de l'en sortir cet été prend un temps
fou devant bleus sont montés à 5000
mètres dans le caucase et 50 personnes
de plus de 60 ans sont atteints au
sommet du mont blanc la montagne pour
tout le monde c'est possible avec le
centre pilote d' escalade de vaulx en
velin qui prépare la prochaine
révolution un stade du parapente il sera
construit là bas derrière les tours